[Music]
if you are looking for a day of fast fun
then look no further than spring
mountain motor resort and country club
in parump i pay them a visit in this
week's vegas drives
welcome to spring mountain motorsports
and country club today you're in for a
high horsepower treat come on
elizabeth thank you so much for having
us i'm super excited to be up here for
the first time what exactly happens up
here at spring mountain we are a private
country club for race car drivers
so
just like augusta national which is a
private country club for golfers instead
of golf we have instead of 18 holes of
golf we have 9.34 miles of racetrack now
someone's watching right now and they
just want to come up here for a day
maybe have a private lesson and learn
how to race a car pick up some racing
skills you guys offer that as well
absolutely yeah you know people can come
out and take one of our driving schools
or they can do a private lesson in their
own car if they have a race car that
they um can use on the track or if they
want they can use one of our cars we do
offer a couple of uh one-day schools can
we see some of the cars absolutely i'd
love to show them today i'll follow you
absolutely holy smokes these cars are
amazing what do we have these are uh
yeah these are some of our club members
cars as i said they do actually drive
their own cars here on track this right
here is a radical it's an english race
car this is not street legal so this is
strictly a race prepped car okay that
they will often use probably our largest
grid on our race weekends that we have
for our club members beautiful and we
also have some club members that enjoy
driving street legal cars like this
gorgeous gt3 this is amazing these cars
are beautiful
did they nice drive can i show everyone
a car can i go for a ride in the car
absolutely we would love to take you for
a ride we're actually going to put you
on our brand new track which is
charleston peak charles freeman let's do
it all right i'm ready for it guys this
is rick malone the chief instructor it's
good to see you buddy guys jc how's it
going great what are you doing to me
today today we're going to take you out
on our brand new 3.2 mile premier world
race course one of the best ones you're
going to see in the world and we're
going to take you on the new c8 corvette
all right i think i'm ready you ready
i'm ready all right let's go jc go easy
you ready to go all right here we go man
[Music]
yes if you're a member you can purchase
a mop and build a home on the lawn you
can this is literally a golf course but
a car enthusiast exactly instead of
driving golf balls we dragged cars yeah
your car's going all day as a car lover
right sit in your backyard drink some
coffee and watch cars go every snap all
day long instead of fairways we have
straight away yes sir if you're looking
for something to do for a day trip or
become a member you got to come up here
to spring mountain thank you so much
rick you're welcome jc can we do it
again absolutely all right let's do it
again i'll see you guys later we're
gonna go do launch control